This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
Hello and welcome everybody. Let's go
ahead and open up those Zoom room doors
and let everybody in. My name is Ruth
Ellen Sanchez and I'm going to be
hosting uh today's daily withdoc and
Becca which is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com.
And today we have an amazing guest. But
before we do that, we always have to
start with
this program is for educational purposes
only. It is this content is int not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician.
The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA and
testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individuals because I'm expecting
that we're going to have some people
come on and talking. that these are
their personal experiences
and we do not make any income claims or
regarding health or either and um you
are an empowered individual and so we're
here to offer options.
Thank you for bearing with me during
that. Um today we have Ivonne Ray who is
an amazing woman and uh an amazing
practitioner
and she is a functional medical nut a
med what is that Revon function med
nutrition
>> I was trying to shorten it yes
>> okay
microcurrent pain specialist board
certified amino acid therapy for brain
health. Um she is former military. Yvon
has worked with pain free worked
painfree for life beta testing research
where microcurrent protocols are
developed. Erasing
erasing oh gosh I can I can't
>> I was also at erasing pain. I was their
nutritional director.
>> Perfect.
>> And and I ran and uh do run the intern
program ship as well. Awesome. Well,
let's just bring you on. Um,
I hate trying to read things because it
always gets like too long or I
But anyway, we're very excited to have
you on today. Um, I've been looking
forward to you coming back on and
talking about this for a long time. Um,
so I'm going to go ahead and let you
finish introducing yourself or um, begin
the talk.
>> All right. we can ask questions, too.
So,
>> well, let's just talk about a little bit
why we're here today. Um, we're going to
be talking about, you know, a new way to
look at um spinal injuries, whether
they're caused by sports or neuro
neurological
um and this can actually be applied to
taking a look at new ways for all types
of uh pain and injuries. Uh I am uh
starting a docu series. It is called the
microcurrent revolution healing beyond
the pill. The pill p I l. And um we're
going to have several parts to that. And
today I'm excited to talk about some of
the spinal injury recovery that we have
been able to assist using microcurrent
nutrition
and gaining strength back so that uh
folks have um the ability to do what
they were told that might not happen for
them again. Things like walk and that's
some pretty big stuff.
>> Yes. Well, I'm very excited to hear
about that. And this is part one of your
series. So, thank you everybody.
>> Well, don't don't quote me on that. This
is part one of our series. I'm not sure
how the producers will line everything
up, but
>> yeah. Yeah. I hope to be able to come
back and maybe even share, you know, as
we go through each of the various tissue
issues. And I know a lot of your
audience understands the the different
tissue issues. Now maybe not by that
verbiage but be reminded if we look at
the four health categories those are
based on the tissues of the body the
primary or basic tissues of the body and
there's four of them. 80% of all
diseases all conditions will come out of
those four tissues. And it's not by
accident that you may not know the
recipes how to help heal those tissues.
Um, but that information is out there
and that is what these folks are here to
do and help you understand and I just
add a little electric love to it and you
know because for some it is electrical
that carries the chemical. So if you
have had a reduction in your electrical
even when and I was one of these, you
know, taking nutrition, I got amazing
results, but there were some areas that
were just stalled out. And so that's
what we'll be kind of focusing on today
along with sharing some stories and
hopefully I got some folks that might
pop in and maybe even give us a story of
their own.
>> That would be great. Very good. I'm very
excited.
All right. So, I'm gonna um go ahead and
let you begin
and I'm going to leave the screen and
you just let me know when you're ready
for a slide.
>> Go ahead, start the slide and and also
any questions that may come up. I'll
just This is not going to be it'll be
somewhat brief. There's only nine
slides, but my hope is I'm a very visual
person that maybe somebody will uh
somebody else will appreciate what you
see.
>> Perfect. Right. Just give me one second
to get the screen set up.
>> Okay.
>> All right. I have slide one up. All
right. Fantastic. Well, as I just said,
we're we are electric beings. And uh if
you take a look at uh Time magazine,
um excuse me, it was New York Times
magazine, uh they did uh you know, piece
on about the body electric and they're
not the only uh Forbes magazines and
many others. But I just want to talk a
few quick moments when we when we get
into some of these injuries. Uh we're
going to be talking uh very spec uh
about using some very specific tools. Uh
this is not a 10 unit and this is not
your typical microcurrent that maybe you
might um you know pick up on Amazon.
These are uh medical devices class 2 uh
FDA cleared. And a couple things that
are really important to understand
like with a 10's unit, uh it does not
penetrate the body. Uh most microcurrens
out there um will be on a different
waveform than the ones that we'll be
talking about today. And just showing a
little bit of a picture. We're talking
about you know high voltage. What the
high voltage does, it is in
microcurrens.
So we are working on the body's
electrical but the high voltage allows
us to go deeper and penetrate uh more of
those tissues.
Um if you want to give me the next
slide.
Oh, that one's kind of wonky. Go ahead
and give me the next one. Sorry about
that.
Um, so in talking about uh electrical,
let I'm going back up just a little bit.
Um, I mentioned briefly that uh
electrical travels and carries the
chemical. So whether or not you are
utilizing um you know prescribed or
prescriptive um medicines or
uh nutrition or even just any food
sources again if there is an electrical
event in the body that is keeping
the electrical slowed down or possibly
even blocked. Now let me just tell you a
couple things that will block the
electrical of the body. One is scar
tissue. Um two is inflammation, swelling
and the third thing is what we call
affected tissue. Affected tissue means
that the body that particular tissue is
not well.
Everything has a oscillation.
it resonates
and that would be they they've placed
some numbers on that kind of like a
radio station. Everything has its own
vibrational frequency
and like organs within the microcurrent
realm are 90 or right around 90 hertz.
If I start to oscillate a little too
low,
you know, maybe I'm coming down uh 15
points and I'm starting to get the
tissue starting to get tired. If it
continues, it gets sick. If it continues
even more, we now have a chronic
condition that is set in. Well, that
electrical, if you're ever driving in
your car and you hit a a puddle, it kind
of bogs down, right?
because it that that puddle actually
slows the momentum. Well, so does scar
tissue inflammation and again tissue
that is affected. So by the use of our
microcurrens they offer BOF feedback
with it. We can go in and check the
tissue bring the help help identify
what's happening there and then bring
the tissue back up. Now that removes a
burden but microcurrent cannot
it cannot rebuild missing tissue. So I
need to make that really clear. So it
really does matter what you put in this
pie hole. And you know I am of the
opinion and education now after my own
personal results that we can't do this
in the way that we're doing this without
supplementation. Now, in our clinic, we
use um clinical doses, also known as
therapeutic doses of um nutrition,
plant-based, and coupled with the
microcurrent,
we see even faster results. So, let's
just take a look right here. This is a
current project that we're working on.
This is after stroke recovery. Uh we
have a program here for that. And uh
we'll just read a little bit about
what's going on here. Four years after a
left side stroke, um uh Ann here just
continued to fail. Uh she was no longer
walking. She uh excuse me, she started
out as a little with a walker but slowly
uh ended up in a wheelchair and with
that decline, the deterioration of the
other limb started to take effect as
well. Uh she came into my office,
someone told her about me and um we
started working on her and some of the
specific complications were a frozen
knee, pointed toe, a frozen ankle. What
happened is that leg was so
there was no bend she couldn't move it.
So with um and this is uh I mean she's
had several therapies um uh Botox
um physical therapy along with numerous
pieces of equipment that were you know
um
utilized that that did not bring along
any relaxation of the tissue. Um,
currently you can see in this picture,
this was about 4 months working
together. That knee is now relaxed. The
leg is relaxed. Um, I went in and was
working with her and her doctor and, you
know, it was just very incredible. Uh,
because it didn't appear to her that she
was going to have these types of
results. Um, our goal is that I'm trying
to get her to be as independent as
possible. We don't really know what that
looks like, but the fact that, um, you
know, she's able to bend and move her
leg, lift her legs, um, we're looking
for that next step.
All right. What do you got next?
So, one of the gentlemans that I've had
the opportunity to learn from is uh Dr.
Dom Dumbroski. Um, and they call him Dr.
Dom or Dr. D. And he's out of Dallas,
Texas. If you want to get a hold of him,
contact me and I'll help you do that. We
also have um others like uh here here in
California towards Southern California
that have these devices. Uh Dr. can
halt. Um, again, contact me and I can
help you get a hold of them. But here,
um, we had a patient, um, with a
cervical contusion. Uh, it was a
gentleman that fell off his ladder and
in doing so, he hit a fence and injured
uh, C5.
Now they were very quick about this and
time does matter in the time of the
recovery as well. So they went in uh
there was actually complete loss of
upper and lower um uh limbs. Uh
ultimately there was a number of things
that were applied uh including the
microcurrent. There are a couple
different protocols that we use on that.
And then the client um purchases a
device, takes it home so that they can
have daily use to regenerate
um along with supplementation
and then at some point we put them in a
strength building program because
remember if the nerves not working
um it's could be a very long time and if
there's no electrical going to that
nerve remember your nerves supply the
electrical and I do want to mention I've
had people ask me there are different
kinds of nerves. There are A, B and C
nerve fibers. And part of what they
delineate is
if it is mileelinated, if the nerve is
mileelinated or unmilinated
and then of course the diameter. Is it
very thick? Is it thin? Now this is
important to understand because when we
start to talk about nutrition
for this specific tissue issue it helps
us understand here it is a mileinated
issue and so because it's mileelinated
myelin myelin is made up of
something like 90 plus% I've seen
variances
of cholesterol
and your good fat fats, minerals, and
water. So, if you are someone who is
struggling here, and I'm just going to
have you take a look at, you know, your
own numbers, but um
get that mileination
back onto this tissue and you're likely
to be able to see even faster changes.
All right, what do we got next? Oh, and
so anyway, he ultimately regained um
normal gate. Um he became ambulatory
again and um you know, life is much
better. It did take a full year uh
before there was complete recovery.
Any you got any questions for me, Ruth
Ellen, yet?
>> Not not yet.
>> Okay. Um here is another this past
project um with Dr. Dom. Uh so we're
looking at transverse myelitis. Uh if I
remember correctly, this one is about
the gray matter um of the spine. This
too would be one that is myelinated and
thus the myelinitis. Itis being
inflammation. So we go in there, we
treat the and affect the inflammation
and the swelling and then we flood it
with circulation
and and high doses of nutrition. Uh
think about this. Uh we we're using a
device that can get us anywhere from 300
400 I've even seen numbers of 500 times
faster blood flow to the tissue.
Do you think if what you put in the pie
hole can get through the tissue, let's
just use the 300 times faster, that that
tissue can heal even better. So no
matter what device you're using, if it's
bringing about circulation, make sure
that what you put in this mouth is
wellness, not illness. And there might
occasionally be one other factor if
we're not seeing the expected results
and that would be sometimes there's uh
um uh you know a body that really truly
needs some heavy detoxification
and I had the opportunity to work with
the detoxification center uh Dan Root
and his dad Dr. David um route and if
you don't know anything about their
program I just encourage you to go look
it up.
Uh but that would be one other thing and
he's doing amazing work in his clinic as
well. Uh back to this uh TM. Uh so this
person was in a wheelchair uh for about
a half a year or a year. um presented
again it was with this weakness along
the spine and so uh what happened and in
I think somewhere in a future slide
we've got some pictures but you'll see
that outside of doing a couple very
specific
um tissue issue with our magic wand here
um we then place pads
and This one again was very uh pretty
quick. Uh within the first four days
they had a change and then was a able to
walk within just a couple weeks. Uh what
is your next slide?
So along with some of the things that
we're doing, we're also and I'm sure
many of you have heard about Vegas nerve
stimulation.
You can do this not even with our
devices, but again, if you're taking in
good nutrition and you do vagus nerve
stimulation, you can affect, if you we
take a good look at that picture, and I
don't know if we can blow that up or
not, but that is cranial nerve number
10. Cranial nerve number 10 innervates
every single organ in the trunk.
So whether it's tapping
And there's many many things you can do.
You can bounce along the side of your
bed, bounce on your furniture. All of
these things can begin to impact the
vagus nerve. This is something else that
we do within our protocol uh
specifically um as we're talking about
the spinal injuries or the stroke
recovery simply because we do know that
there is a brain gut access and I
personally call this the frontal spine
because it does and offers and touches
everything that um our our the spine in
our back touches. is uh so I think that
this is an underutilized
um uh nerve and the more that we learn
about it and I'll I just really give
credit to Dr. Rob Van Bergen uh he did
his thesis on this and if you get an
opportunity to read that just incredible
uh just how that alone can make impact
for all types of injuries.
Next,
earlier we talked a little bit about
that white gray matter. And if we take a
look at it, um
can you can you see my mouse?
Is my mouse impacting anything? No,
probably not. Uh this would be a
crosssection of the spinal cord. You can
see clearly the gray matter and the
white matter. So again, we're talking
about mileelinated, unminated, and then
when we talk about AB and C fibers, it
really will be about the um the um
dimension, the size
uh of the nerve as well. Um and with the
spinal cord, you know, everything gets
fed through there. So if there is low
voltage to these tissues, we feed it
nutritionally.
We bring along our tools and devices to
start to open up um any of that
electrical and simply we do a test
measure and correct. So the goal is to
raise that voltage
um of that tissue and um continue to
feed and then we can walk into that next
um uh stage. I've shared this story
before. I'm not sure if I've shared it
here, but we had a gal
who had been um in an auto accident. Uh
she was in a coma for 4 months. came out
uh 41 years later. Somebody uh suggests
that she come see me because she had uh
a foot drop and within about 4 months
that foot foot drop had completely
changed. Uh it it's it's kind of fun.
She would when she came to me she was
falling four to six times a day. Um, and
because her arms didn't come out to
catch herself, she was reinjuring
because oftent times she would hit her
head again and again. Um, maybe it was
uh about two and a half months. Um she
was
walking
and she had a glass in her hand and she
said, "Ivonne, I fell today and as I was
falling, I set the glass on the table."
And she fell and her arms came out. But
not only because one of the other things
that we're doing is we're working with
propriception. Propreception is huge.
Athletes know all about propreception.
But it was about that eye hand
coordination which was also very
challenging for her. So some very
exciting stuff that um uh you know we
can help with and that is um potentially
uh
yeah just potentially life enhancing.
Next slide.
All right, here's another um project. Uh
now this one is the um transverse
myelitis. Did I didn't I already talk
about this one? I think my slides might
be out of order.
Or did we just talk about the spinal
contusion?
I'm sorry. I thought I had put them in
order because I just downloaded them
and I can't um see.
>> Let's just go to the next one.
>> Okay. This is like
So, we've been through them all.
>> Oh, there we go. That's that's that's
one of them right there.
>> Sorry.
>> That's okay. Thank you. Yeah. So, um you
know here again talking about uh you
know the arms unable to come forward. Um
this particular that was uh one person
this particular gal um had a stroke and
for four years she was uh declining.
This was one I think I mentioned just in
the in the beginning. But if you take a
look at the picture that shows where
after we do a couple uh protocols with
our tools, uh we got her started on all
the nutrition.
I'll tell you that alone made a ton of
changes. Uh but you'll see
where we've made some pad placement and
that's uh very crucial. And what we did
is literally we're just flooding the
area now, reducing the inflammation and
then now where there's atrophy, we are
just enhancing the circulation
and um uh we've got the upper
extremities working. She's combing her
hair. She was uh not able to write at
Christmas time. she could not write for
and you know fill out her Christmas
cards um by Easter or even before
Easter. Um she was doing that. She folds
clothes. She does dishes. I mean she's
doing all of these um upper body daily
um activities as we continue to work on
the lower limbs.
And so there's just a few things. I
think I've been talking for enough time.
And um Marilyn, if if you have some
other questions, just uh let me know.
And I realize I think I I missed a
little bit. Did I talk about the ABC
nerve fibers and the mileination?
>> No, I don't think you did. Uh do you
want me to reshare?
>> Oh, no, that's okay. um uh just you know
a lot of times people are not familiar
there's the as far as nerves go so part
of my training has been in neurology
it's a map and it follows everything. So
if you begin to or if you have a
challenge, find out what nerve that is
on and then follow it back up to uh uh
one of the spinal nerves, but ultimately
all nerves originate in the brain. So,
you know, chiropractors that are called
like upper cervical, they that's why
they say that they can actually help
improve the my um um tissue challenges
further down because ultimately
everything all of the nerves originate
in the brain. So sometimes they're only
working on the cervical and um we're
kind of coming in I I come at it at both
ends. If it's your foot, I'm going to
give some love to your foot. I'll also
give some love to the cervical area and
anything else in between so that we can
gain clearer uh pathway uh and get blood
flowing. And again remember it is the
electrical that travels the faucia that
carries all of the chemical uh reactions
and responses in the body. So if it's if
it's slow um this may be one tool that
um would you know you could try to um
get restoration get some recovery.
>> That is amazing. I just am fascinated by
uh all of what you're talking about. I
mean, I had to have surgery and um it
disrupted several nerves and so I
understand how long that can take to
regenerate and and connect. And it just
blows my mind how um without telling
anybody anything, but how one set of
nerves is attached through the fascia
and if that gets disrupted then you
can't really read what you're doing on
your muscles at all. Like I'm literally
having to learn how to
connect to parts of my body that got
disrupted. So, it's amazing work. I need
to come and see you for sure.
>> Yeah, we'll we'll we'll take our little
tools and we'll apply to the area and
then I always follow that map.
>> It is simply a map. It's a map like what
Dr. Wall put together with the four
categories with the um you know nearly
100 essential nutrients. Um uh it it's
you know it's we're not guessing. Um
also with our tools at least on the
electrical we can go in because it's a
um microcurrent with bio feedback. Um we
can see the tissue issue. we can see um
you know the uh amount of voltage how
healthy the tissue is or isn't and then
we can go in and try to help move that
either up to or down from you know um an
angst state.
>> Nice. All right. So AJ has his hand up.
I am going to um bring him on the screen
with you. Let him ask his question.
>> Hi AJ.
>> Hey Von. How are you? I'm fantastic.
It's good to see you.
>> Good to see you as well. Thank you for
all that you do. I have a number of
questions.
Um so get ready. Um first and foremost,
let's start. Um so you said, uh blood
flow to the tissue 300 to 500% more
efficiently. I'm paraphrasing.
Um,
so
>> and that's according to the company.
>> Okay, I'm not going to debate that. What
I am getting at getting at is number
one, what what device will do that or
all your devices capable of doing that?
Number one. Secondarily,
uh is there a way to target the whole
body at one time or is it just so what's
the recommendation?
So when we're talking specifically about
spinal um we're uh targeting first uh
some of the very specific tissues
involved like the gray white matter, the
nerves, the other nerves and nerve
endings of the extremities. So we've got
to get several things up and going. uh
on occasion again there's there's a
whole brain connection and so we do also
uh work with that
um and then most of my tools I have
several frequency type tools whether
it's scalar you know terraertz
um all of them offer uh specific uses
uh the the latter that I just spoke of
those are really um beautifully targeted
about the blood and helping the blood,
helping clean the blood because you know
like I've heard you and many others on
your show talk about dirty blood. So
I've got some that will be very specific
to the blood but not necessarily
increasing in blood flow. But with our
microcurrent with BOF feedback, yes, at
these specific settings, we can increase
blood flow. Um, Stanford and Baylor did
some testing and like I said, I've seen
a couple different numbers, but between
three and 500%.
>> Okay. Um
and then so so is the mechanism of the
electrical charges is the mechanism to
increase electricity or is it to
increase blood flow bringing nutrition?
What is the mechanism that heals? Is it
>> that is super fun to know? All of it.
All of it. And you know what we can
offer with these prescriptive devices is
I'm just going to show you this screen
real quick if that's okay. Let me get
over to a
mode that shows us BOF feedback
and I you know touch my skin and just a
moment.
So, if you tell me if you can take a
look here.
>> Oh, yeah. I can't see a thing.
Let's see.
>> Okay.
>> Try tilting it down. Try tilting it
down.
>> And actually, I'll give it just a
moment. The the light goes off after 10
seconds. And so
now you should be able to see it.
>> I see. 136 102 37651.
>> Yeah. So see that 65.
>> Mhm.
>> First of all, that tells me that's the
XY co-actors. That shows me that I have
a block.
See that 36.
>> Uhhuh.
>> That's information about the health of
that tissue that I just touched.
>> And then one is a timer, the other one
is power. And then if you see the one in
the lower left,
that actually shows me just like an ohm
meter. And this is going to clear in
just a moment.
It started out at 19. Just an FYI, I'm
touching
my wrist and that should go off.
>> Four.
>> Now look at that double six.
So, that tissue right here at my wrist,
I did have a um motorcycle accident.
Okay, it just went off. I'm down to a
two. Still a double six. It'll it'll
come back up for you to see.
Still at a two. Here we go. M
>> so it's it's showing me in real time
how the tissue is not only affected but
how it's responding
to the treatment.
Now what I'd like to see is that double
six clear.
But if I don't
it's okay still because what I'm doing
is from the tissue to the brain and
back. It's called a closed loop neurom
modulation.
Many BOF feedbacks out there do an open
loop. So you bring the brain's attention
to the affected tissue.
>> Okay. Didn't really understand a thing,
but I have one last question. So uh I
understood I'm just joking. So uh um one
la well well not last question but one
uh additional question. Um
uh I have a woman who uh had lymph nodes
taken out
and uh does a lot of uh not not draining
lymphatic
uh well the lymphatic system not drain
not working well and always gets uh
swollen legs type of thing. Is there
something electronically
or is there a device that you think
might uh h give her some relief or
assistance?
>> Absolutely. Um but I would also be
looking at other tissues uh regarding
the swelling. It's not always the lymph.
Uh sometimes it's a heart, sometimes
it's a kidney. Um there there can be
more than one causation. So we do an
extensive history
and and she's and and and um I I I do
I'm I'm familiar with metabolic syndrome
issues and and we've uh done a lot of B
vitamins, d-stress, those sorts of
things and um ultimate daily classic and
she's using longevity lymphatic support.
But I think that um
maybe maybe I can set up a a call where
you can maybe chat with her and and and
go into in depth.
>> Sure. Let's see if we can't find her
some easy relief. Worst case scenario,
she would have a non-invasive
tool that she can keep her symptoms down
and restore voltage. We do know if
they've removed anything, there will be
scar tissue. There will be swelling.
that tissue is affected. And so you want
to address those things. Um and then
we'd find out, you know, if in fact that
that um was from the removal or is there
something more going on?
>> And if if folks wanted to contact you,
what phone number would they use? Our
office line uh if you want to send a
text, let us know that you you know saw
us here and is 916
8907.
Excellent. Thank you. Um
all right, so we do have somebody out on
Rumble. Um, pure being and let me move
this so I don't have to turn my head so
far.
Um, says, "Glad to be here. Yvon is
amazing and I've been blessed to know
her for many years. Glad you're having
her on." So, thank you. She's amazing.
Um, and glad to hear Oh, wait. I think I
duplicated that. And then um she said
something about a spinal contusion
uh and it was kind of broken up because
she was responding to what you were
saying. And then have you noticed
certain types of cl of clients or
conditions respond especially well to
the avesa
microcurrent device compared to others?
Um yes. So um I have used and tested
others. Um and I would say that this one
by far um there's not another one out
there that offers bio feedback. Now you
know there's Russian devices out there
and this was initially developed simply
because of the Russian devices. Uh but
with Tim Smith who is the um engineer
behind it, uh couple things that are
pretty darn spectacular are, you know,
you got a dual split chip um which
allows us to do
more than any other one I've seen. Um I
think the protocols um I I have um
trained with others uh both that use the
Russian device as well as um some of the
other American devices. I've trained
with them simply because their
perspective if they're coming um at it
as a chiropractor, as an MD, uh you
know, we have so many I wish I would
have had some of these um uh some of my
eye goggle um but eye health um you
know, we've had um opthalmologists that
are using these for everything from
glaucoma to cataracts. My both my
aigmatisms um are gone. Uh my eyesight,
if you've ever heard me tell this story,
uh my my glasses were a 4.0.
And then after using the nutrition and
the microcurrent and listening to Dr.
Ronald Pew, if you guys remember that
one, he challenged uh Dr. Wallock to 25
blind, legally blind patients and they
all had uh you know, varying degrees of
sight restored. So, my eye health went
from a 4.0 to a 2.5 today. It is still
at a 175. And I don't know if I'll ever
not wear glasses. Uh partly because I'm
a hit or miss on my own protocol. Um uh
but my eye health is definitely improved
simply by you understanding my
prescriptions coming down. uh it had
continued to go up for years. When I
started the supplementation that halted
it and kept it there, but then when I
started the microcurrent, I've been
going down. So, the two together have
really um initiated. And I want to say
for pure being, you know, I don't know
if he was able to come on, but I got the
opportunity to work with him. He's a
detoxification center and uh to work
with some New York uh police and New
York firefighters uh that were at 911.
And anyway, I'm just want to give them a
real shout out because they're doing
stuff kind of like me. I mean, I'm not
seeing anybody else uh doing what Dan
Rude is doing. So, thank you Dan for
saying hi.
Yes. Thank you. Sorry. I always get a
problem. Um,
and he says, "Please tell Ivan it is
Dan, I guess." Thank you, Dan, for
saying that. Um, and then Ivonne on
YouTube
is saying, or I'm sorry, Olga, please
forgive me. What is the difference
between small home uh small home
microcurrent device for facial
treatments and the ones you've uses?
Well, for starters, it's going to be the
depth that it reaches. The second thing
is the voltage. So, that would be the
depth. Um, next it will be um the
waveform that it's on. So, our tools,
both the home and the clinical, these
are on what's called the sinus wave. So
everything of nature, plants, animals,
ourselves, we are on a sine wave. We
recognize that when we see an EKG,
right? Uh most all other uh microcurrens
are on
uh a man-made like a square wave, a saw
to a triangular, or sometimes they'll
layer them on top of each other to to
make greater impact. And it's not that
they can't get an effect, but most of
those are not on a microcurrent. Um,
excuse me. Uh,
they're on a microcurrent, but they
don't have the voltage for the depth.
So, you can certainly see some changes.
Uh, and there's a couple other things.
One would be that we have the reactions
technology, which is the BOF feedback
closed loop neurom modulation. So we are
literally going to engage the brain with
the tissue at some point in our journey.
the the tissue said, you know, um like
for me, I had a motorcycle accident, you
know, my my back and I was taking um
prescriptive
um for way longer than it was ever
prescribed for, but they kept giving it
to me and I felt great during it, but I
think ultimately I continued to have
greater injury. Uh I herniated the disc.
It's now two years later and it had
stretched and is now pressing on two
inches of my spine. and I went to go
stand up and couldn't stand up. Uh so
with these devices, what they not only
allowed me to do was to find the root or
the problem after the healing had
occurred. Um and then I I mean you can
you can register it. It's it's
registering and it engaged my brain. At
some point my brain said, "Ivonne, talk
to the hand. We got work to do." How was
it that I had all of that going on and
yet I could get up every morning and go
to work? You know, I had a commander who
who he said to me, he said, "Yeah, you
know, I I heard about you before you got
here." And this was at Oakland Naval
Hospital,
uh, you know, you were supposed to be
this stellar,
um,
you know, person, sailor, and you know,
I'm not really seeing that much from
you. my spine was being crushed and we
didn't know it. And so I would go to
work, do my job and come home. Go to
work and do my job and come home. And I
know some of you guys are doing that and
there, you know, just anything else. But
when we begin to open this up, um, this
will make a change. Nutrition made a
huge change.
>> Yes, it does. It it it definitely helps
a lot.
All right, we have Marilyn with the
question.
So, let me bring her on.
>> Marilyn.
>> Yes. Hello, Yavan.
>> Hi.
>> Wonderful to see you. Uh, we were
talking earlier before the show. Um, our
distributor, we have a longevity
distributor named Bill. What? So, it was
the Aazio device that
>> Aazia.
>> Okay. And so, he can rent it. he rents
it now from you or
>> Well, Bill took the step and wanted to
get one of his own because he saw what
was possible and rather than spend his
money on continued renting, uh he is now
part of the the family and he's actually
getting getting himself trained as well.
So, we're really really excited to see
the many many changes that are occurring
with Bill. So this gives bof feedback
and does but it also emits frequency for
the healing.
>> Yes. Yeah. We can detect, we can measure
and we can treat. It actually I I'll
even go a little bit further just to
tell you um and this was really about
you. Anyway, it's like a 5in1 generator
in the fact that I can use it as a
microcurrent. I can add on through this
little opening other tools like um
oh here's one this and this is one of a
couple different types this would be a
pillow so for PEMF so now pulse
electromagnetic field I can resonate
tissue specific nerve bone whatever
tissue specific and this will um uh
drive about 8 to 12 in into the body.
Now, some people have a very very large
pad of these. So, earlier AJ asked about
the whole body. There are devices out
there that are really spectacular. Um,
but most of them are set on one of about
four to six settings uh for circulation,
for relaxation,
but you cannot control
much more than those few settings. Uh, I
think the hertz are 10, 30. I saw one
with 12. And then there might be one
that's a multi.
>> There's one that's real popular called
the Beamer.
>> Oh, yes. I own them.
>> Oh, okay. So
>> yes, and I own and I I we have the new
generation Beamer here as well.
>> Cloud. Yeah. It's called
>> Yep. Yep.
>> Fantastic tools, but these are very
different. They do not engage in your
electrical system. Let me make that very
clear. They do not engage in your
electrical system, but they are
providing you a PEMF
um therapy, which we've seen great uh
results. not as swiftly but you know
many people will feel it and I did as
well. Um uh
yeah and if you want to reach out to me
I can tell you about some of those and
get you in touch with um you know a
regional distributor and that might be
able to help you out.
>> Okay. And what I don't really know what
you mean when it says you do it does not
engage in the electrical system
>> because isn't that what it's really
doing? That's what
>> No. No, it is not. It is permeating
a wave form into like when I hold it
like this, I can work on um chest,
lungs, I can put it behind my back, work
my spine, and then with our tools, we
get very, it's tissue specific. I can
turn this right to spine, right to bone,
right to nerve. This here
actually will engage into our
electrical. Let's see. I'm right here.
Um, but a PEMF can not. It will enhance
the um area that it's in. It's going to
give it a better uh setting. And I'm
trying to remember we were talking about
oscillation in the beginning. So imagine
if you walk into so I work at radiant
light and I walk in and the space is
filled with scalar energy.
So scalar is very calming to everything.
Um with PMF
you can you're enhancing the
environment. You are not working you're
not actually engaging the body. But when
you enhance the environment, have you
ever walked into a space and maybe it
was too loud, there was, you know, too
much of these other things and you kind
of felt angst, that's just impacting the
environment.
I hope I'm kind of saying that pretty
clearly. And if we ever need to do a
PMF, well, um, while I use it, I'm not a
complete expert, but I think you guys
might have even had somebody on that is.
Well, my husband had a stroke, so I
wanted to I was just looking for a
device for him. What would be the best
device for him?
>> Well, um if you already own those,
absolutely use them. If you don't for
the same almost the same cost, uh you
could literally first of all uh work on
the tissue of the scar because that was
an electrical event.
And then you can start to work on the
individual areas that have been
impacted. And we're going to flood it.
We're going to reduce swelling. We're
going to increase anything that is
starting to atrophy. And I got to use,
you know, starting to tire too much.
>> Okay. Fantastic. And AJ did a scalar
scan uh for me and I thought it was
utterly amazing. 10 pages of telling me
I had too much silver in my body or I
needed vitamin K or I needed to eat
pistachios. It was amazing in five
minutes and he said he learned it from
you. So I would highly recommend that
for anyone the scalar scan. I thought it
was amazing and it gave me so much
insight to my own body like you know it
says if you have parasites, if you have
uh toxicity from fertilizers, all kinds
of stuff like that in depth. So
fantastic. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
Okay. And we have um one question in the
chat. Um
it is
Huh. Okay. Um
I'm sorry it just disappeared on me.
>> Is that the arhythmias?
>> Yes. Does the does do any of these
devices work on with heart arhythmias?
So, let's just talk about that a brief
moment. There could be a couple
different causations.
Um, if the causation is structural,
meaning that you have that nerve that's
being impinged and it'll be coming down
the spine. Yes, we can kind of go in and
start to open up
and drop that swelling so that there is
no impingement on that nerve. and it's
very clearly marked. There'll be areas
that are very clearly marked along the
spine. Um I would do vagus nerve as well
as uh work the spine for that to see if
maybe that is in fact the tissue issue.
Um unless you've been told that there
was something else going on. Um that's
where I would start.
>> Perfect. Thank you. And Bill has his
hand up. Um, so I'm going to
>> but at a very minimum start, you know,
if you're not already doing the
nutrition, that's a given. Okay? And
anytime that's always remember
microcurrent, none of these tools,
scalar can rebuild missing tissue.
They're going to begin to remove burdens
from your body. Um, and then what you
put in this pie hole again, is it
bringing me illness or wellness? And you
got to do it in clinical doses. Uh if
you've ever been to my classes or seen
my class, it's called size matters.
My size matters next to the next guy who
may be larger or smaller. So we want to
be sure that we get in enough of the
clinical dosage, not your store shelf
dose. Remember, they don't actually they
FDA guidelines tells them what they can
and cannot say on that bottle. So, um,
we're always talking about therapeutic
or clinical doses here.
>> Yeah, it's very important. Dr. Wik
always says, you know, if you treat
everybody like an animal,
treats us like dogs because if a dog is
five pounds, you would give them one
kind of medicine, amount of medicine.
And then if the dog is like a 50 pound
or 100 pound dog, we have a friend of
mine has a really humongous dog that
comes up to my hip and that dog would
need different amount of medicine. So we
have to keep that in mind. And you're
right. If we don't give our body the
building blocks, the things that are
going to help the mortar and everything,
then we can do all the different
treatments that we want, but we need to
feed the body's ability to make the
changes that we want.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And if you're Yeah. Again,
if you're on nutrition and it's not
helping you, find a different brand or
look into the possibility that maybe
you've got a little electrical slowdown
or block. And that's different than an
energy block. Let me make that part very
clear as well. Some, you know, do what
they call energy clearing. That is
actually different than electrical.
We're literally coming in to raise the
voltage,
>> right,
>> of the tissue. All tissue has a healthy
range of voltage and when it drops or
when it gets too high, that tissue is
going to be angst or tired or sick. And
so the goal is to bring it back into a
closer to normal range. If we can engage
the body, if it's been longterm, things
are going to happen even faster.
>> Yeah.
>> Simply because when the brain's
involved, healing happens faster.
>> Yes, it does. All right. So, um, did you
have a heart stop today? I forgot to
ask. Normally,
>> I did. I did not.
>> What is AJ?
>> Barbara D has a question about spinal
stenosis.
>> Barbara, unmute yourself.
>> Bill has had his hand up. I'm happy to
ask Barbara's question.
Barbara, if you can unmute yourself, go
ahead and then we'll go to Bill.
So,
>> are you ready for me now?
>> Yes. Go ahead.
>> Um, yes. So, my husband was diagnosed
with spinal stenosis and I was just
wondering if any of these modalities
could help him. So, your first modality
definitely will be nutrition because
that spinal stenosis as you probably
know is narrowing of the inside of the
bone, right? So that narrowing will
begin to impinge upon the other nerves
and then depending upon where the
narrowing is and if it's on the right
side, left side, straight down the
middle, what it's going to impact is
what happens. Um ultimately the
nutrition. So um that it the body puts
up its own scaffolding. It's still
remember um connective tissue which
under the diet the four health
categories actually falls into hard
tissue. So you know do the recommended
for hard tissue but then yes you can
come in use these tools for a couple
different reasons they would help. Part
would be inflammation two would be
increasing circulation. Also, we there
we have um um on our prescriptive
devices, there's a bone stimulator
and so now you can make things happen
even faster. The the regrowth
um of that.
Wow.
>> Excellent. Thank you.
>> Yeah, that is amazing.
That we got to talk about that because I
have somebody in my life that needs
that. All right, Bill. Um, if you could
unmute yourself and ask your question.
>> Okay.
Great to see you, Yavon.
>> Hey, Bill.
>> It's been a little bit.
>> Hear you.
>> Okay. We're good on the sound.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Uh, hearing Yavon starting in
June. I was fascinated with this. Going
online to the website painfree for you.
I would, my wife and I, we went and
visited her in December. I had three
treatments. It's quicker than it should
have been. We should have waited some
time in between because we did uh two on
the Thursday and on Friday we did one in
the morning then left. It should be
separated. But I had a pain level from 1
to 10. Um I was at 12 most of the time
and those two treatments for four and a
half weeks my pain level went down to a
four.
It's not just the nutrition, it's the
blockage. Like we're saying, if we don't
absorb it, it's not doing us any good.
So with the nutrition,
change the diet years ago and with the
nutrition, we became better. So I would
recommend anybody
that if you possibly can get fly into
Sacramento, drive whatever you need to
do and come and see her. This is a
miracle.
uh device, but it's not the device. It's
learning to use it.
And so we are getting better and better
and better and better. And uh then in
turn we can help others to be better.
But I thank you tremendously.
And
>> and Bill, I love that you you took the
first step. you you told me you were
going to come out and I do hear that and
that that can be a big expense but um
>> it was
>> you made it happen and you know you are
now in I if all we can do in the
beginning is change the trajectory of
that tissue one degree and he had I
think we had a total of probably about
uh one two three four uh sessions
four degrees five degrees he's already
that tissue is already going to be going
into a different place.
>> Correct. So what so we are changing the
nervous system
that has to be changed and then uh
getting oxygen and blood flow to the
rest of the parts of the body.
>> Yep.
And uh number one thing if you get one
of these instruments just the vagus
nerve alone clearing up the intestinal
digestive system the uh other side on
our right side Vegas nerve uh deals with
the heart and lungs.
We all need to breathe better
anyway. Thank you.
>> Thank you Bill. And you know he said
something that I just uh he said breathe
better. We are doing and have been doing
a um a lung trial. Uh
and so if anybody does have chronic lung
conditions um the trial I can send you
the information. My my goal is to prove
the efficacy of this home device as a
first response to keep you out of the
ER, much like an inhaler,
but by dropping the inflammation
and uh allowing you to breathe better.
So far, we've been able to um we're
closing in on 100, not there yet, but we
have been following the tests and 3 days
later, their oxygen levels are still
improved after one treatment. That
inflammation in that scar tissue, you
know, let's get in there and start to
try to move things out.
Yes, the scar tissue definitely needs to
be moved and broken up and moved out and
inflammation is
so detrimental to so many people.
>> Yeah,
>> thank you.
Um, I don't have any more questions that
I see and unless
my chat is like gigantic in Zoom, so
it's hard for me to read because I can
only read one chat at a time and it's
really long. Um,
so thank you so much. I'm really
grateful and I'm hoping after the today
we can set up your next visit with us
and um continue on your uh docky series
a little bit on our show anyway. I'm
looking forward
>> Yeah. And and that next one is actually
going to be brain brain injuries um and
how we affect the skull plates and the
senoid bone. Uh and it's kind of
interesting because we actually do it
distally
uh through all the tendon work.
So we don't touch the brain.
>> That's that's amazing. But when when you
see some of the
um when you see some of the um uh x-rays
and some of the changes uh that have
occurred just in the body by by doing
this protocol. Uh it's it's pretty
impressive. It's a and some call it an
autonomic nervous reset uh system reset.
Um
we don't call it that. uh because it can
I mean it can help realign.
>> Um but with the brain injuries uh it's
really something else and and maybe we
can even do it live.
>> I would love that. That would be great.
>> Yeah,
>> would be really good. All right, so tell
everybody uh one more time how what is
the best way to get a hold of you?
Uh well, if you'd like to um
call or text, our office line is 916
8907.
Um ideally, if you go to our website,
>> it's forabetyou2.com
like it says at my name right there.
>> Right there.
>> Um
And then
>> that would be most ideal simply because
sometimes um uh you know the texts and
the phones um they they can they can be
lost.
>> Yes. Email too it can get it can get
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. Okay. So that's four the number
four and then a better you
and then the number two.com.
>> Yes. And or you can go check us out
microcurrentacademy.
Let's see where am I?
Microcurrenacademy.com.
Tada. Nice. Okay.
microcurrenacademy.com.
Excellent. I'm definitely going to sign
up for your school
for sure. All right. So, if I could get
all the co-hosts to come up and join us
on the screen, then we can um, you know,
say goodbye to everyone. And
I'm just so grateful that you were on
today because
I love
this topic, you know. Um, I want to get
you on with Tim Marsh. I want to get you
guys together because your philosophies
are so similar but totally different
modalities and I think it's just going
to be a great show and AJ definitely
wants that was his idea too. Um, all
right. So on the screen we have Sherry
who is part part of our uh tech crew and
helps get all the platforms set up and
takes the signal that I send to her and
then sends it out everywhere.
And we have Phyllis who's out on the
different platforms who is also posting
everywhere that needs to be posted. And
um
she's also responsible for Dr. wallet
getting on the radio. Her and her
husband Andy. So, she is
are I I just so grateful for that cuz
none of us would be here if it wasn't
for all the work that you and Andy did.
So, thank you for that. And then
Marilyn, Miss Speedy Fingers, who is
typing and dictation and typing almost
every single word. And I don't know how
you do it, but somehow you managed to
look things up and then paste them in
the chat with the same.
You're very impressive, Marilyn. Thank
you.
And we have Albert who is in South
Africa and is our gatekeeper
and he um is the person that would
answer the phone in the middle of the
night um when we're all sleeping because
it's day morning for him and it's like
10 o'clock at night for you right right
now.
See that's dedication.
And then we have AJ who's our digital
marketing director and part of our tech
crew as well. And um
everywhere that you see us out there is
because he helped us get there.
And um
there is no words for the gratitude
for that. AJ, you're amazing. And then I
want to give a shout out for our uh
fearless leader Rebecca Dukes as she's
traveling and um helping out with her
family and um we're so grateful to you
because you helped create all of this as
well. So thank you for that. Um if you
would like to speak to a health coach,
you can call 855-9493377.
And if it's the middle of the night,
you're going to get out.
Oh god. And then um if you have
questions, you can uh email us at
questions at dailywooddoc.com.
And if you need um
there's one more I'm forgetting.
It's support, right? Support at
dailywithdoc.com.
If you have other questions then you
need information then we can help you
with that. Also this program was for
educational purposes only and the
testimonials of the individuals were
their personal experiences
and
remember always be kind. You don't know
what somebody's going through and
sometimes it's a really hard thing, but
they're going to fake it until they make
it and smile and be happy and joking
with you and go home and cry or cry on
the way home or cry on the way some
sore, whatever it is. You just don't
know. People are going through a lot
right now. So, always try to be kind.
And you don't have to be perfect, but
just do your best as a human. Thank you,
Ivonne, so much. I am so grateful that
you were here today and um that I could
do the show.
>> Thank you for the opportunity to make
awareness for microcurrent.
>> Yes. Yes. Have a beautiful day everybody
and we will see you tomorrow with Dr.
Judy Reynolds. Thank you so much. Bye
for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, bachelor
of science and plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.